ohne scheiß meine hand ist ja sooo groß
und dieses das ist schon echt süß was
wird wie teuer es werden zehn euro
das ist eine beleidigung wörtlich wenn
man facey die auf wunsch bestellt
das passt ganz gut der deckel war immer
hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen video ja heute ich hoffe
natürlich geht es gut
es fühlt sich wirklich sehr real an
unreal auf jeden fall freut es mich
wirklich sehr dass ich heute endlich
dieses video drehen kann ich habe vor
glaube ich war 33 monaten zäher so ein
mini-iphone xs tarif wie auch immer kann
also ein ganz kleines smartphone
angelehnt an das iphone xs aufgestellt
das war zu der zeit wo kommune
ausgebrochen ist und so weiter und der
liefertermin hat sich immer weiter
heraus gezögert und dann noch weiter
heraus gehört und dann nochmal weiter
heraus gezögert und bis heute ist das
gerät nicht angekommen
100 euro monatlich oder irgendwie 80
europa nicht super schade und dann habe
ich das vorgestern noch mal bei amazon
bestellt war noch mal 130 euro also ist
ein sehr teures video heute aber das ist
es mir wert weil ich wollte dieses
produkt unbedingt haben wir haben hier
das ist wirklich so angekommen also ich
habe das noch nicht aufgemacht oder so
man kann einfach so machen ich weiß gar
nicht warum das überhaupt hier in dieser
verpackung gesteckt haben hätte
jederzeit auch ausfallen können na ja
auf jeden fall ist das hier das sony sxs
ihr seht schon das dingen ist es
verdammt klein also es ist wirklich ein
mini smartphone ich habe mir gedacht ich
will es auf jeden fall bestellen ich
möchte das testen und ich möchte das mal
so ich möchte mein großes iphone mal
beiseite legen und dann halt irgendwie
24 stunden dieses mini iphone benutzer
weiß vielleicht auch ein bisschen
schwierig ist das iphone zu nennen also
es ist auf jeden fall angelehnt ans
iphone xs ich denke aber mal das design
ist dann auch das einzige was einem
iphone ziemlich lag alter ist dass
kleinmann koma ohne scheiß meine hand
ist ja sooo groß und dieses
das ist schon echt süß ich muss mir
gleich auch mal die technischen daten
von diesem gerät angucken
wir ziehen das thema ab da wird einfach
schön herangezoomt das ist doch immer
das neueste des geländes schön hier
unten steht drauf so jetzt
wahrscheinlich sprechen dass wieder
komplett falsch aus und hier auch
nochmal die folie ab es ist wirklich an
sich schon nice und es ist auch wirklich
schwer also das ist schon ein schweres
gerät ich würde fast sagen dass es
schwerer als mein eigenes iphone und das
ist ja viel viel größer ich gebe euch
hier natürlich auch mal ein paar
aufnahmen von dem gerät also ich finde
schon dass ich frage mich sowieso muss
man ständig so ein großes handy in der
tasche haben reicht ja auch manchmal
einfach hier
dieses baby bringen dann wird man das
jetzt nicht an
es scheint so als müsste ich es erst
aufladen krass was ich finde wir haben
hier einen usb typ c dabei und dann kann
ich das jetzt natürlich dann gleich mal
an machen
wir haben ja auch direkt eine
schutzhülle dabei und ganz standardmäßig
wie beim iphone auch diese kleine nadel
um hier die sim-karte rauszukriegen da
muss ich brauche eigentlich eine neue
mode oder was passt denn hier ein mini
sie ja okay er sonst nämlich einfach die
von meinem iphone
also ich lass das jetzt mal auf und dann
testen wir das und dann benutze ich dass
die nächsten 24 stunden
das wird echt meist und vielleicht
danach noch länger dann kann ich das
hier verschenken oder ich verschenkt das
hier
wer weiß also wir sehen uns jeden moment
wieder aber du kommst jetzt erstmals
laden hier ja jetzt ist es an
ich dachte schon so hey warum geht das
nicht anders hätte wäre ich jetzt so
perfekt gepasst wenn es einfach kaputt
wäre zu einem ganzen pech was ich eh
schon mit diesen dingern habe okay leute
einige zeit ist vergangen
das ding ist jetzt endlich mal
hochgefahren hat jetzt 27 prozent
geladen und so sieht das aus also
wirklich ja der winzigkeit eben und ich
habe gerade schon geguckt wenn ich das
jetzt hier entsperren
es sieht noch mal deutlich mehr nach dem
iphone aus als ich überhaupt gedacht
hätte weil die icons hier kommen wir zum
teil bekannt vor wie zum beispiel das
einstellungs icon die uhr das kontakt
icon und ja galerie ja es ist alles ein
bisschen verändert aber schon nicht
schlecht von touch funktioniert echt
leid also schon flippig so geiles ding
bevor ich das jetzt mit dem internet
verbindet alles andere weitere
einstellen muss ich mal kurz die sim
karte wechseln
ich habe es schon geahnt nicht brauchen
eine neue sim-karte weil das ist größer
naja da müssen wir jetzt erstmal los war
gibt so sind leute was geht ich bin es
halt im auto ich habe leider meine
wangen kam nicht dabei sonst würde ich
dir jetzt natürlich benutzt haben ist
ohne vater kamera da stehen auf jeden
fall kurze updates grad 1 prozent auto
verloren so der akku schon ganz gut zu
sein ich habe auch gerade schon die
kamera getestet gebt euch das mal worte
macht zeigt euch jetzt mal hier die die
front camp so sieht es aus also an sich
ich habe mir die tatsächlich schlechter
vorgestellt auf jeden fall bin ich
gerade auf der suche nach einer sim
karte für das gerät habe gerade einen
anruf gemacht jetzt wollte ich gerade
los wenn jetzt habe ich noch ein anruf
bekommen weil wenn ich mir jetzt eine
sim karte kaufen würde die wir halt erst
morgen aktiv weil man da irgendwie sich
personifizieren muss dann muss das halt
erst bestätigt werden und das dauert ein
bisschen deswegen und freund von mir
gearbeitet in seinem geschäft wo die so
auch so adapter dafür haben und er
bringt mir jetzt gleich einen adapter so
dass ich doch meine karte von meinem
iphone hier reinstecken kann dann haben
wir das problem schon gelöst jetzt sitze
ich hier schon im auto und ich denke ich
kann trotzdem jetzt schon mal versuchen
mir hier ein paar apps drauf zu ziehen
was braucht man denn so mir fällt grad
auf ist ja nicht mal youtube darauf dass
uns auf jedem handy schon scheiße jetzt
muss ich das wlan passwort
ach komm egal wir gehen einfach wieder
rein es bringt ja nix gut dass ich nicht
jetzt gefahren und jetzt fängt es an zu
regnen und auf jeden fall habe ich jetzt
schon mal internet das problem ist nur
oder was heißt probleme also ich bin
eigentlich ganz gut damit klar gekommen
wieso muss ich mich jetzt wieder neu
verbinden wir haben gerade leichte
collection probleme und zwar bin ich
einfach ich glaube der wlan router ist
bisschen zu weit weg für das handy so
dass ich jetzt doch kein internet hat
coop war erstmal wie klein die tasten
sind man muss erstmal die richtige
treffen und suchen glaubt das geht ja
super ich bin doch verbunden ach so
jetzt ist ja auf chinesisch eingestellt
weil jetzt bin ich mal gespannt ob ich
trotzdem hier ist mein video schauen
kann über den internet browser
ich muss das erst mal auf deutsch
stellen denke deutsch so ok das haben
wir schon mal und uhrzeit
heute ist der jetzt los leute jetzt habe
ich es richtig eingestellt wir haben
heute den 29 sechsten und das ist jetzt
1517 glaube ich zumindest keine ahnung
ein youtube video läuft trotzdem noch
nicht
dort hängt irgendwie verbindungsprobleme
webpage not available
irgendwie komisch leute was gedacht ich
habe jetzt gerade hier eine sim karte
erhalten allerdings muss ich dir glaube
ich jetzt alter das wird es auch was
obwohl das könnte klappen
schöne grüße gehen hier aus an vodafone
kann man ja mal kurz sagen kleine
werbung außerdem habe ich jetzt auch
schon whatsapp und youtube installiert
das heißt wenn die sim-karte drin ist
ist das smartphone voll einsatzbereit
dann kann ich euch da auch noch ein paar
mehr sachen sagen die ich gerade
aufgefallen sind bei mir läuft auf jeden
fall mit meinen beiden handys das hier
ist aber jetzt mein geschäftsfrau nur
für business ich glaube es sieht gut aus
ja es klappt es jetzt muss ich hier noch
meine pin eingeben und yahoo leute das
liegt doch sehr gut jetzt habe ich noch
kein empfang ich habe auch noch elf
prozent ja also der akku ist jetzt nicht
bombastisch ist halt okay für dieses
dinge aber als ich gerade erst whatsapp
und dann youtube installiert habt das
wird so heiß ich rufe jetzt gleich und
marie an was ziemlich aber auch frage
komme ich jetzt wirklich genau neben dem
wlan router und habe einfach nicht mal
annähernd wollen weder in empfang was
das denn
ok jetzt geht oben ist der halt komplett
weg das bisschen schade jetzt wäre
kannst du einmal kurz mal dein handy
nehmen dass hier halten haben wir hier
zeigen
von der rückseite kommt man das kommt
auch gute leute merlin hatten iphone xsl
fo nix wenn ich es besser
das kann ich marie anrufen also wir
haben jetzt so weit alles eingerichtet
ach scheiße jetzt bin ich wieder hier
oben und habe das auch das wlan reicht
nicht bis hierhin kabinetts man also
mein neues handy gestellt mich auf jeden
fall schon so vor die eine oder andere
herausforderung dann müssen wir wieder
runter
wir stellen das mal ein bisschen lauter
es nur fünf prozent
energiespar modus aktiviert hey ich bin
gerade in meinem neuen handy aktiv wie
das gut aus entschuldigung wie vom
toaster scheiße zu wägen grüßen
[Musik]
nein
ok dann lege ich jetzt wieder auch dann
richtig gar nicht stören beim sporttag
was soll das denn heißen
also ich muss sagen die bildqualität von
maria hofer gut verlustig wenn man das
so ganz klein sieht was willst du total
war aus werden zehn euro
das ist eine beleidigung leute was geht
ich habe gerade gesehen also ich hab ja
mal ein anderes handy praktisch gerade
ich hab ja airports hochschulen jung nur
kurz zum angeben
ich habe mein anderes handy komplett
lahmgelegt komme ich habe jetzt zwei
neue nachrichten von irgendwelchen
nummer einfach so weil ich hier und
aktiviert habe ich habe gerade auf jeden
fall zwei stunden videos geschnitten und
war gar nicht am penny und jetzt habe
ich natürlich wieder kein wähler die
irgendwann das ist so dumm
es ist auf jeden fall eben wieder
ausgegangen jetzt haben wir 46 prozent
akku weil ich das ungefähr eine
dreiviertel stunde geladen habe
weil ich ungefähr eine halbe stunde
geladen habe ich glaube das ist ja noch
mal so
die hälfte heute ist er wirklich so dumm
ich hab' ich bin nicht weit vom wlan
router weg aber ich habe einfach kein
empfang wird euch mal kurz einmal ein
youtube-video jetzt sein kann man kann
es auch so drehen dass wahrscheinlich
nicht
ach so ich bin halt nur auf toilette
weil wir besucht haben und ich konnte
nicht ins wohnzimmer
das wundert euch nicht an die qualität
von video ist auf jeden fall nicht
schlecht das ist wirklich ein sehr sehr
großes problem ich kann in meinem zimmer
gar nicht mit den dingen arbeiten weil
hier kein internet ankommt ich weiß aber
dass das video sicherlich auch viele
technik leute schauen deswegen muss ich
euch mal kurz hier die technischen daten
zum gerät zeigen also warte man das
interessiert mich selber nehme ich auch
obwohl ich eigentlich kein technik kann
aber ist ja wichtig war so was ne so es
ist unglaublich manchmal hier ne warum
geht das nicht auch krass alter ich sehe
gerade das hat sogar face id das wusste
ich gar nicht neu wird hier
quad-core-prozessor blitzschnell 2 + 32
gb arbeitsspeicher als wenn
unterstützung für langzeitspeicher
spiele app high definition kamera der
heide finde ich nun also ich glaube das
meiste was da steht stimmt nicht aber
gesichtserkennung müssen wir noch
checken den gerätespeicher hab ich eben
abgecheckt 2,9 gigabyte fotos und videos
und musik kannst du darauf machen also
für die heutige zeit ist das natürlich
schon ein wenig nach aber an sich ist
das ja auch nicht so teuer und ziemlich
klein okay leute wir machen jetzt ein
bisschen face id mäßig wörtlich wenn man
facetime auf wunsch bestellt ja das
passt ganz gut wenn wir einmal das war
es schon ich mache es als vor meinem
gesicht
jetzt hat es wieder geklappt aber gut
das muss ich auch sagen das habe ich
schon bei vielen handys dass die
gesichtserkennung mit trinken
solche angst anders kommt rein
was läuft bei mir sieht es gut bei dir
ach so ja ich habe neues handy soll mini
iphone oder so deswegen hört sich das
war schon ein bisschen komisch ein
gerader oder oder geht es heute übrigens
an die die sich fragen warum ich mich
immer hier auch heute liegt am wlan
router weil sonst kann ich halt mit dem
ding nicht so viel machen ich würde mir
gerade mal ein spiel jetzt sagen
überlegt was ich euch noch zeigen kann
irgendwas schauen wir mal ihr könnt in
der zwischenzeit super gerne
kommentieren könntet ihr euch vorstellen
so ein kleines handy wirklich zu
benutzen tagtäglich oder was meint ihr
dazu
das ist ja wirklich sehr sehr mini
schreibt es meine kommentare würde mich
sehr interessieren und kanal abonnieren
auch wichtig leute ich habe mir jetzt
subway princess gezogen das kenne ich
noch gar nicht ich kann nur sauer surfer
cola also das eigentlich hat es viel
viel schlimmer eingeschätzt dass
reagiert recht gut oder oder liege ich
da falsch
also ich hatte damals mein erstes handy
hacker server das spiel kennt man ja
oder da ging das nicht mal also da hat
subway server iis geleckt und es war
nein ich will keinen tick tock
installieren da oben und das war
wirklich ein viel größeres handy
aber gut ist auch ein paar jahre her wie
gut ich bin abfahrt könnte ich das
drehen
die werbung da oben nervt mich das hat
auch schon jeder mensch auf der welt
tickt da müssen dann noch mehr werbung
leute wer ist jetzt gleich auf jeden
fall abend das singen ist ich komme ja
hier aus diesem corona kreis deswegen
sonst hätte ich gerne auch meine ganzen
freunde weil das handy gezeigt aber hier
darf man gerade nicht raus
beziehungsweise nur zu zweit und so ein
bisschen ja sonst hätte ich eigentlich
auch noch einen coolen blog hier
ausmachen können
aber ich glaube dass wir trotzdem ganz
cool also das handy gefällt mir auf
jeden fall wird man wahrscheinlich auch
beim angelus in der öffentlichkeit und
wenn man so ein kleines ding hat oder
falls ihr noch irgendwas einfällt was
ich euch zeigen muss dann melde ich mich
nochmal ansonsten wir uns jemand heute
abend später wieder
ich zocke jetzt gleich noch eine runde
und dann gehe ich auch schon okay wollte
mich mal kurz das licht an
es wimmelt es von 19 neue nachrichten
also das schreiben mit dem ding ist
wirklich ziemlich anstrengend jeden fall
was ich sagen wollte ich jetzt gleich
kernig stellen wir jetzt jemanden wecker
geht das überhaupt mekka für 38 passt
youtuber lifestyle habe ich jetzt auf
jeden fall an gemacht wir sehen uns
morgen früh wieder biss dann leute was
läuft hier können ich glaube ich nicht
selbst das mikrofon überhaupt ist ja ach
ja deutsche was geht ab kurzes fazit
mehr was ich jetzt so davon halte also
ich muss sagen mega das gerät erstmalig
bereue überhaupt nicht dass gekauft zu
haben jetzt über amazon wie gesagt
glaube ich 130 euro kostet oder so das
gibt es auf anderen plattformen ich auch
für 70 oder 80 euro und wenn wir uns
dann auf den preis fokussieren ist das
eigentlich ein ice halt box schon ist
etwas ganz anderes ist ziemlich klein
für leute die dicke finger haben
vielleicht nicht optimal weil du triffst
heute die tasten nicht der akku ist
vollkommen in ordnung kamera weiß nicht
so gut an sich hängt sich das gerät
jetzt auch nicht auf so wie es bei den
meisten 80 euro handys der fall ist
nicht bayerisch bestellt haben oder so
wobei manchmal wirklich schon so ein
bisschen überlastet und dann geht
einfach die app zu das hatte ich jetzt
schon zwei mal stimmt trotzdem muss ich
sagen hat ultra spaß gemacht das zu
testen ich hoffe das video hat euch auch
gefallen ich verlinke euch das neben
einer beschreibung abonniert auf jeden
fall den kanal lasst doch nach oben da
würde ich mich sehr darüber freuen und
ja ich könnte mir immer weitere produkte
stecken die ich mal testen sollte freue
ich mich mehr drüber wir sind uns
sonntag wieder gibt es ein neues video
haut rein kommen hier doch meinen neuen
kanal alex v